Let us begin then with the subject of today,
which is the few,
every educated person should know what a few gifts.
Why?
Because it's an intellectual model and intellectual paradigm.
That surface is in a number of disciplines.
For example,
uh,
in poetry,
oddly a,
if you've ever peaked at Thomas,
uh,
ts Elliot's the four core tents,
the structure of a few is referenced there frequently we could go to literature,
uh,
a novel written about the same time,
Aldous Huxley's point,
counterpoint,
it's framed in the shape of a fugue.
We could go to geology geologists.
Occasionally we'll say this particular crystal has a few like structure to it
turning to painting.
There are painters of the 20th century,
I can name at least three fronts.
Koepka all the violence and Josef Albers who used to be the dean of our own
school of art and architecture,
they all painted fugues and we will be looking at Albers fugue,
which actually happens to be in your textbook,
uh,
when we come to section a this week.
So be sure to bring your textbooks to section this week cause cause we'll,
we will be using them.
I'm interested in the few also because of this book.
Douglas Hofstadter's girdle,
Escher,
Bach.
Oh my,
it's heavy.
My mind,
I didn't bring in my copy.
This is the bass copy that Linda was kind enough to pull over.
Mine is a paperback.
It's not this heavy,
but in a way this is indicative because it's heavy reading.
Anybody ever peaked at this book in hand?
The other good is it Adam?
Yeah,
Adam.
Uh,
what course did you read this in?
Um,
recommended by friends.
I can follow about the first 25 or 30 pages or so.
Then when it gets to the math,
it really gets over my head.
But what it is is an attempt to use the fugue is a way of bringing a common mode
of understanding to the visual arts,
to mathematics and to music.
The musician that is,
uh,
foregrounded here of course is js Bach,
the master of the few.
So we want to know about how fuse operate.
So let's take a take a look at the specifics here.
The term fugue actually comes from an old Latin word [inaudible],
which means flight or to fly.
So in a few of what you get is one,
a voice going ahead,
leading ahead and another voice following it.
Now I just used the term voice there.
Fuchs can be written for,
uh,
actual voices sounding voices or they can be written for instruments such as
the,
the violin or the cello individual lines.
It can even be written for instruments that can play several lines are several
parts at once.
The piano can do that.
The Oregon can do that,
even the guitar and occasionally the violin will be asked to do that.
Fuse had been written for as few as two voices.
You asked,
you could have a two voice few up to as many as 32 voices.
Uh,
and uh,
they can be,
uh,
as mentioned,
um,
uh,
written for and they are best perhaps performed on these keyboard instruments
that have the capacity to play many lines,
many parts,
many voices that once the greatest collection of fuse as you may have,
uh,
may have bumped into,
heard about or at least heard the term is this collection of preludes and fugues
by Js Bach called the well tempered clavier.
First of all,
what's a prelude?
It's just a warm up piece.
Started getting relaxed.
You get to see your fingers get a feel of the keyboard or the of the loot or
whatever it might happen.
Maybe be a prelude to pre play a warmup.
And then we go on to the meat of the issue,
uh,
which is the fugue now,
why is this called the well tempered clavier?
Anybody know?
Anybody have,
that's an odd term.
Clivia just means keyboard.
The well tuned to keyboard thoughts there.
What,
what was going on in box day is that they didn't have a keyboard
dead.
They didn't have a tuning system in which all of the pitches were exactly a half
step apart,
somewhere slightly closer together and then others farther apart.
And the key of c actually had a slightly different sound than the key of d.
And it's only in the 18th and 19th century that we gradually shifted from an
unequal keyboard to an equally tuned to keyboard.
So Bach is kind of part of this transition to the equal tuned keyboard.
He was getting close to the equal temperament of the modern keyboard.
And that's why he called it the well tuned a keyboard.
And it,
uh,
by tuning it this way,
it allows you to modulate to all keys.
And that's what he did in this collection.
He wrote two books,
one in 17,
about 1722 and he was in Curtin and another about 1742 when he was in Leipzig.
And in each of these books we have a total of 24 preludes and fugues one the
prelude and fugue in c major one prelude and fugue and C minor one prelude and
fugue in c sharp major and one prelude and fugue in c sharp minor and so on.
It goes all the way up the keyboard in that fashion to books or those.
And that,
this is kind of standard fodder for those that want to become professional
musicians.
Okay.
So that's what,
that's what,
uh,
that is,
about the well tempered,
well tempered clavier.
Uh,
we've been referencing Bach here and nobody of course,
uh,
wrote better fuse than j s Bach.
Uh,
some continued,
some continued to write fuse.
Mozart wrote some cubes,
Haydn wrote some Fuchs,
Beethoven wrote some cubes and so on.
And even into the 20th century,
we have a few composers,
Paul Hindemith used to teach at Yale.
Uh,
Dmitri Shostakovich.
they wrote,
but generally speaking,
the few has its heyday in the Baroque period,
roughly 1600 to 1750,
the hay day of Bach and Handel.
How To fugues work?
Well,
they start out as mentioned with one voice leading forward and then another
voice imitates that voice.
Exactly.
Now,
if that following voice,
here's a question.
If that following voice imitated the leader exactly from beginning to end,
what would we have?
Hmm.
Around.
Okay,
good.
That's what we would have around,
or we could call,
use the,
have the fancier music word,
a Canon Canon round the same thing.
One voice imitating the other.
Exactly from beginning to end.
But in a few of what happens is after the main idea,
which we'll be calling the subject,
the main idea is stated,
then the parts go,
they're independent ways,
uh,
generating counterpoint.
But they're not exact.
They're not a precise duplications of the rhythms and the pitches of the
leaders.
So what we could do would be to visualize this in a,
in a sort of a crude way up here,
do you have a leader?
And then a follower and the follower duplicates the main idea,
which we're going to call the subject for a period of time,
but then it kind of breaks off.
So voices will come in and duplicate a certain amount of material and then break
off and go their own way.
So that's a good way of thinking of the beginning of a few,
which we will call the exposition.
I'll come back to that point in a moment.
Notice here,
I've put a little silly little tree up here.
We could say that we have the,
uh,
the genus polyphony here and we've gotten monophonic texture,
homophonic texture and polyphonic texture.
So within polyphonic texture we have non imitative texture and then a stream of
imitative polyphony and then two forms of imitative polyphony rather strict.
Exactly.
Strict imitative polyphony,
the cannon and less strict imitative polyphony is a few.
Yeah.
Okay.
Questions about that so far?
All right.
Let's go back to the beginning of a few.
We have this opening melody,
the distinctive part of it,
which we're going to call the subject.
That's just what we call the melody and a few the subject and the way this works
is in a,
in a few,
each of the voices in turn will come in with that subject.
One we'll start out,
then another will come in.
Then another will come in after all of the voices are in.
We're at the end of what we call the exposition of the few.
Now we've had the term exposition before.
Where was that?
Uh,
over there.
Elizabeth.
I hear you.
Yeah.
Sonata form.
It's not a allegro form.
So we and what do we,
what do we mean by exposition?
There was a chance where you present all the,
all the,
the themes and we talked about first theme,
the second theme,
closing theme.
We're here in a few.
We have just one theme,
but everybody's going to get a chance to present it.
And after everyone has a chance to present it,
every voice has a chance to present it.
Then we're finished with the exposition.
All the voices have exposed the theme in their range.
After that we go on to what's called the episode of a few.
What happens in an episode?
Well usually it modulates key and the vehicle through which composers frequently
modulator is melodic sequence either up or down.
You can kind of move around.
By using sequence,
you can get to different places by using sequence.
So it tends to be uh,
a contrapuntal because it's using little motives from the theme.
It modulates,
moves around a lot,
goes to different keys,
sounds a bit unsettled.
If you were to think back on Sonata Allegro form and try to find an analog for
Sonata Allegro form in the few episode,
what would it be?
What is the episode of a few like in Sonata Allegro Form Roger?
Exactly the development section.
So these episodes in a few are sort of mini development sections.
So visualize if you will,
we start out here with the exposition in which all voices present the subject.
Then you have this kind of free period in which the,
the motive out of the subject has played with develop moved around different
pitches.
Then the subject,
we'll come back in a new key because we've modulated in the episode and subject
in just one voice,
new key.
Then another episode in which there's modulation,
more counterpoint,
more movement and other statement of the subject in a new key,
uh,
another episode.
Now their statement of the subject and on it goes until we run out of energy,
usually about after four or five minutes or so.
Uh,
at which point the composer will bring the subject back maybe in the base or in
the soprano in a very prominent range in the tonic key.
And we haven't,
since this is a very solid moment,
yes,
this few is ending.
It may be the throw upon one or throw one or two courts on at the end,
but that,
that's it.
Uh,
so it's a complex form but maybe not quite as complex as a allegro form.
what's a definition and if you're taking notes there,
what's the definition of a few?
Well,
I wrote a definition of a few and I will read the definition out of the
textbook.
Students don't like this,
I found if you read out of a textbook,
but I ought to be able to do this since I wrote the textbook.
Okay.
So,
um,
I'm going to read,
read a good definition of a few cubes,
a definition of the few,
uh,
composition for two,
three or four parts played or by voices or instruments,
which begins with a presentation of a subject in imitation in each park.
The episode,
excuse me,
the exposition continues with modulating passages of free counterpoint,
the episodes and further appearances of the subject and ends with a strong
affirmation of the tonic key.
Well,
you can't write all that down,
but if you want to just put in your notes for definition of few,
see page one 44 of the text.
Fortunately,
as I say,
uh,
it's easier to hear and look at fuse a than it is to define them.
All right?
Now,
today we're going to do something different.
It's the only day in our course where we're actually going to look at music.
Okay.
We've handed out music for you,
an entire piece and entire fugue by J s Bach here.
And ideally I guess we'd be in the,
in a seminar format and we'd all be standing around the piano here.
So my first question for you is for how many voices is this few written?
Look at just the first page and look vertically and see what's the maximum
number of pitches you have sounding simultaneously at any one moment.
Um,
Caroline,
is it
three?
Okay.
Yeah,
we have three.
If you,
if you look through there,
there sometimes at the very beginning there's just one voice and then there are
two voices and then the three voices,
three lines.
But it never gets to be more than three lines.
So we have our x position here and it consists of three statements of the
subject.
We're going to call these three voices or,
or lines,
the Alto,
the soprano,
and the base,
which comes in,
in bar a seven there.
So here's the little bit of the beginning of the,
okay,
so that's our exposition because each of the voices,
Alto,
a soprano and base has come in and presented as this subject.
Then we have bars nine and 10 here.
What's that?
If I just go,
Jerry,
what's that?
It's a melodic sequence.
And which direction is it going up or down?
Well that's hard.
Maybe harder than you think.
Okay.
Really going down.
Not because the line is going down,
but we're starting
each time on the successively lower pitch and this sequence takes us.
So we've started in this kind of tonality,
which is minor,
but now by the time we've gotten to bar 10 and 11 particularly,
he's modulated.
So that's what our little episode was in bars nine and 10 there.
It allowed us to move from a minor key to a major key and now the subject comes
back in and as you can see what voices it in there?
What voices the subject in in bar 11 pretty straightforward.
Somebody yell it out
the print.
Okay,
so here,
heads up in the subreddit.
So there we are.
Nice statement of the seam in a major in the soprano.
What happened in that little episode?
We were here and now we're here module.
He did again to minor and is there in bar 15 where's the subject?
Which
Chris Alto Park.
Good,
thanks.
So there it is in the alto part.
That's an interesting moment there because we've got a three voice few and how
many hands does the performer?
Half obviously too.
So at some moments these hands are going to have to share a subject and that's
what happens in that voice.
When you play this.
Take a look there.
The very last measure of that page,
it must be 15 starts out,
my left hand is playing here
and then the left hand has to get out and pick up the counterpoint in the base
and the right hand takes over that subject.
But it's the job of the pianist.
There are the keyboard she was ever plaintiff to really lean on the inside of
your hand there because when you normally play play these instruments,
there's a tendency,
and I'm sure Santana Santana's far better keyboard said,
I will confirm this.
There's a tendency to roll the either side.
It's easy to play bass and soprano.
It's hard to do is to get those inner voices.
So there's the keyboard player after,
so you can really hear that.
If you didn't hear it,
then that wasn't a good performance.
All right,
now that takes us across the page.
There were now back in a minor key.
Uh,
this is bar 16 and 17 in bar 17,
18,
19 beginning of 20.
We have an interesting moment.
It's called invertible counterpoint.
What do we mean by that?
Well,
he has a motive.
Okay,
we're going to call that motive a,
and he has another motive motive be.
So there's B and the alto a in the base and together they sound sort of like
this.
Okay,
cool.
Now,
next three bars.
What happens?
Well,
he takes be
and so he takes B and puts that below a,
he's switching the positions.
You're a is,
no.
Hmm.
Both of these motors are coming up in rising sequence.
So let's go back to the beginning of 17 there and we'll listen to the switch.
All right?
So that uh,
goes by very quickly.
Right.
How long do you think it took the Bach to,
to figure that out?
Yeah.
I don't know.
He's a very good contrapuntal.
This may be boom like that.
I'd have to sit there.
Santana,
how long would it take you to figure out some invertible counterpoint?
Did you get think of one melody,
think up another Melly they would be a harmony against it,
but yet you could flip the two and it would still sound pretty darn good.
They take a long time though.
It kind of work that out.
So that's what's kind of neat about few,
there's all these intricacies imbedded in them that almost sale by the,
the general listener unless we happen to have the music right in front of us and
couldn't dwell on them.
All right,
so that takes us over now to bar 20 where we are here,
back I guess tonic of c minor and the theme is up in the soprano.
And then one final statement and the soprano.
A couple of interesting points there.
When we concluded this piece,
we had this sale.
What's a little bit surprising about that?
We're ending a piece,
it's called a feud number two in c minor.
We are ending here with
sounds like a minor chord at the end.
Now the major court.
All right,
so he's changing.
This is a standard gambit gambit from the late 16th through the 18th century
last chord.
They didn't like to end pieces in mind or maybe it's too depressing.
Well,
I do that.
So yeah,
the major third up there,
but that's called a picker d third,
maybe from the old French word [inaudible] which means sort of sharp or pointed.
So we have a pointed ending there.
We have a major day.
Here's another Po,
uh,
issue,
when we're all,
since we're on the topic of points and that's called a pedal point.
What was j s Bach known as in his day?
Was he known as a great composer?
Who was he known is,
how do you earn a,
basically how they earn his living?
He played the,
if more,
yeah,
he played the organ.
He was the Great Oregon Virtuoso of his day.
And I think at the end of this particular few here,
it's interesting he just has that line sit there.
Okay.
On the Oregon that would just be fine and Dandy because you'd put your foot down
there on that low c,
you know we go
and
that tonic note would continue to hold.
But if you were writing this for the clavichord or the Harpsichord or the piano,
what happens to that sound?
Once you hit it,
it dies away.
I think in the end of this piece,
buck had the sound of the organ.
He didn't read,
he wasn't thinking,
Jesus,
this is really for,
for Harpsichord or something.
I better write this like this.
So we get a nice strong tonic.
Sounded the end.
He may have had the sound of the Oregon there in his ear,
but perhaps the important point here is this idea of a pedal point,
cause we've actually even talked about that before in the Yohanis Brahms'
variations on the theme of Haydn that was performed Saturday night.
Pedal point is what anybody can define pedal point for us.
Hmm.
Well what goes on,
it's pretty simple.
Oh Roger.
Yeah.
A base,
holds a note and basically you're just kind of running over top of one,
possibly two.
Harmony's up above it,
but it all sounds continents a consonant.
So,
uh,
just be issuer of the idea of one that note usually in the basis holding,
holding,
holding for a long period.
Um,
Linda,
turn them
volume down the hero.
How many?
Wow.
Okay.
Uh,
any questions about that fugue by Js Bach?
Anybody want to ask anything about that?
Marcus,
that works for you?
Ghana.
Okay.
That he has no question.
Um,
Frederick.
Oh,
okay,
good.
Yeah.
Thanks for bringing that out there at the end.
We could even have your right for me be even five notes played at once.
So this idea that you,
once you have three parts,
you can only have three parts or once you have a five voice,
few you can have no more than five voices breaks down at the very end.
Why would you imagine the composure would want to do that,
Fredrik?
Well,
well no,
it's not that hard because you don't want you to get used to the idea of a c
major triad.
You have musician would look at that end and say up,
I've just got to see major trying to manage a bang down on it.
So that's not hard technically or intellectually,
but why would it come?
They raised a very interesting point here.
Why would a composer want to add more notes at the end?
I think it's a pretty straight forward idea.
Deep Michael Micheal.
Yeah,
just make it louder.
Make it's more snores,
big bang endings sort of thing.
Yeah.
To tell the listener once again that this is something special that we're
probably at the end.
All right,
so let's listen to just a bit of this.
We've had one version of this.
Let's listen to a contemporary jazz ensemble playing.
It starts out with a kind of guitar synthesizer with a piano here,
and then we'll see what other instruments are.
Here's,
here's the jazz rendition of the same few by Bach.
Ooh,
what instrument is playing this baseline?
Okay,
here we are in bar 1315 subject in the inner voice.
Here's our invertible counterpoint
switch,
subject soprano,
just modulating from one key to the next tier.
And here they actually do repeat that tonic note.
Oh
cool.
And then what they do is go off and improvise.
But it's interesting the similarity between jazz style and jazz style and
Baroque music.
Why is that the case?
Well,
Baroque music has a lot of driving rhythm is kind of regular regular rhythm in
it.
And jazz has a kind of regular pulsating rhythm in it too.
I asked you what instrument was playing the baseline there and uh,
Daniel,
you started going like this,
so what were you doing the double bass of this year?
But is it a,
is it bode?
No,
it's a pluck to Pitsa Ocado double bass.
But that's a standard instrument in a jazz quartet,
Jazz,
jazz ensemble.
But it's a,
it's a very strong base.
And Baroque music also has a very strong base,
so lots of similarities between contemporary jazz and a baroque music.
And sometimes these jazz ensembles like to get to this baroque music and,
and resurrect them in a modern idiom.
Uh,
all right.
So normally a few cause a freestanding piece where you could have an entire
movement written as a Fugue,
uh,
heightened court,
last mover,
Haydn quartets.
We'll sometimes do that.
A Beethoven Piano Sonata might do that,
but usually they're freestanding pieces.
Occasionally you run into a few that's embedded inside another movement.
You might have a movement in Sonata Allegro form and you'll get to a particular
section,
let's say the development section.
And the composer says,
well,
I want to write a few here as my development.
When that happens,
we call it a few Gato,
a few gato.
So if you got doe is a few placed in the side,
another form.
So we're going to listen to an example of this from the romantic period in which
we have the young composer George Bz.
He was exactly you were age when he wrote this.
He was 19 years old.
Uh,
George Bza wrote this symphony,
there's a lovely romantic strings sound sort of break your heart string sound.
And then we have a segway.
We have kind of a romantic transition here as he changed his mood.
And then a few we'll break out.
And it will start in the bottom voice.
I'll tell you that much.
And my question to you or my challenge to you is this,
what's the order?
Let's say,
and I'll tell you this,
we got a four voice fugue that's going to start here.
Can you track the order in which the voice is enter?
You know,
you've got the four,
you got the bass,
tenor soprano or bass,
tenor alto and soprano or soprano,
Alto,
tenor bass.
They can come in any one of four different,
um,
we'll probably even more than four mute permutations,
but the order might be a alto base,
soprano tenor.
It might be based Alto,
tenor soprano or soprano,
alto,
tenor and bass.
And we don't know.
And that's your challenge here to see if you can track the subject.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's talk
all four voices here.
Is there,
could anybody on just one hearing?
Tell me what the order was.
Uh,
okay.
Let me chew,
uh,
somebody,
the differs here.
Robert,
I haven't called on you this morning.
Okay.
Start with Beta.
Maybe even.
Okay.
Then where did it go?
Yeah,
it actually went to the house
and there then when Tinder.
Yeah.
Okay.
And though we're going to get a,
uh,
an episode in which he's going to play with just a motive and then the subject,
we'll come back.
So here are two questions for you.
In what,
which voice is the subject coming back and what's happened to the subject when
it comes back?
It's changed in one way.
[inaudible]
stop it there any takers on that?
If we're doing a quiz on this,
we'd give you three or four plagues of that,
which,
uh,
voice did it come back in.
That is,
uh,
not bad.
We would take that,
um,
because it's kind of high 10.
I'm playing a kind of Tinder range here.
Uh,
I think it was more cellos and we'd probably with bassoons would public call
that base base for it,
but,
but fair enough,
tenor and what happened to him,
Roger?
So He'd modulated to a different key and then gave you the subject in a minor
key.
And that's kind of the way these,
uh,
fuge operate.
Give you an exposition episode,
which you change key,
bring back the subject in a different key.
All right,
so we've now had a few from the 19th century,
although we would call it a few Gado because it's embedded in this lovely,
lovely Sonata Allegro Movement.
Um,
let's turn to a few from the 20th century.
And for this we go to Leonard Bernstein and you can see the playlist up on the
board.
Uh,
new haven used to be a favorite tryout city for Broadway musicals.
Deed.
There was a musical entitled never went anywhere.
It was entitled,
we bombed in new haven,
meaning that the tryout of the particular musical was not a success.
And where would they,
where would they try out in new haven?
What was the great theater for this?
Hmm.
That Yale Rep theater and the other takers.
Okay.
The Shubert theater.
Yeah.
Actually in that period,
the Yale Rep was actually a functioning,
a house of worship.
It was a church at deputy.
What's now the rep?
Uh,
so was it the Schumer theater,
which has been here for a long,
long time.
So Leonard Bernstein came in here with a show in 1952 called wonderful town and
he tried it out there and generally speaking,
and it was a success and he took a download toilet train tracks there to
Broadway,
but he took some music out of it.
So music that he thought actually it was a little bit too complicated for the
choreography that he wanted to to work into.
It.
Leader took that material and worked it into a freestanding piece called prelude
and fugue and jazz riff.
So we're going to look at now just the,
a few good portion of it because it's a very interesting kind of,
phew,
it's a very complex view.
So we're going to start out here and I'm going to break this.
Well listen,
we'll stop and listen and stop,
uh,
so that we can,
um,
uh,
focus on particular passages.
So as we start to listen,
uh,
see how many voices there are in Leonard Bernstein's few,
have a general sense of what the range is,
Soprano,
Alto base,
uh,
what else do we need?
Oh yeah.
What instruments are playing here?
So that's,
uh,
the exposition.
And little bit of a development there.
So what instruments?
Hmm?
Ducks.
Yeah.
Saxophones.
Okay.
Nealon said,
says saxophones.
These,
right?
Yeah.
So saxophones.
Um,
so we've got roughly how many did you hear?
Okay.
Two,
three,
four,
maybe four,
maybe four days.
Fringe Saxophone,
sorta.
Alto Sax,
maybe Baritone Sax in there.
Um,
and there was one.
And so we're,
we were playing this out in this rather a syncopated,
uh,
a few stubby top p p p.
P.
Papa.
Let's listen to it again.
No,
we don't have time to do that.
But here's one thing that,
that happened,
that kind of sound.
Then after one episode,
one of the sacs is brought back that Sabine,
what's it doing there?
What is that?
What's the relationship there?
Yeah,
it's just,
it's just inverting.
It was taking the intervals and flipping them.
And that's what composers love to do with fuse.
And we'll be talking about interchangeable parts,
reciprocal relationships with the mathematical quality of fugues.
And so that's what's happening here.
We have a moment of melodic inversion and sometimes in Fuchs and box did this in
a musical offering.
He can take his few subjects and run it backwards,
run it backwards from beginning to end.
So they like to have these kinds of mathematical permutations of these
intervals.
It's a very cerebral stuff,
this few business.
So there we had just a moment of Leonard Bernstein writing,
um,
uh,
a little bit of inversion.
Now what we're about to hear next is something of a surprise because we get a
second fugue subject and it's a different fugue.
Subjects did not support syncopated is rather lyrical dog,
something like that.
So it's nice and nice and lyrical and let's listen to how he know full unfolds a
second fugue subject.
So what we have here is called a double few.
He's got one exposition with one fugue subject.
Now he's going to give us some completely different exposition with yet a second
fugue subject.
And then number one comes back.
Okay,
we're going to pause it here because he's now about to do something rather
interesting.
The Bach used to do as well and Bernstein was a consummate musician,
uh,
and studied Bach had bought coming out of his ear,
so he knew about this particular trick.
It's called stretto.
You can design a fugue subject.
Uh,
not only did it could go upside down,
but in which the intervals instead of coming in long,
this succession could be piled right on top of one another.
So the way he sets this thing up to begin with is this,
this and maybe this and then this.
But in the next section it's going to go this,
this,
this and this.
The intervals back up on each other because they had been arranged to be
consonant at key points and that's called stretto.
Uh,
Italian word stretto kind of tight tight entries here.
So here is a fancy little bit of counterpoint by Leonard Bernstein that once
again goes by very quickly.
Yeah.
Now he's going to bring back the two subjects together.
We have one in [inaudible],
two together
episode,
episode
one,
two.
So it's a pretty nifty little few of there by Leonard Bernstein with lots of
intricate counterpoint,
uh,
involved in it.
All right,
let's end now with a few of Js Bach.
And for that we're going to turn to an Oregon fugue that he wrote about 17,
10,
17,
10 when he was a young man in Weimar here.
Is that fugue subject?
Hmm.
Mom bought hot,
hot,
um,
Palm Palm,
Todd,
and on and on and on.
It goes.
What's of interest about this subject?
Well,
two things.
First of all,
uh,
as a sing this,
oh,
Bob,
what is that?
Uh,
it's a
Arpeggio.
Yes it is,
but it's an Arpeggio of what
you should try it.
Just to minor triad might attract one five,
three,
one.
If I skipped this note here,
blah,
poppy,
palm,
as they come to every strong beat in this team,
every strong beat,
I have a member of the triad that seemed either g,
B flat or d.
So these trials,
as we said before,
are really the structure,
the backbone on which a composer like Bach will place the flesh of a few
subjects.
So it's very triadic and it sounds pretty secure for that.
Now here's another thing that this fugue subject does and many other few
subjects.
It starts with quarter notes,
Yom quarter,
quarter,
quarter.
Then next measure
eight,
eight.
And then we get in here,
eight,
eight d,
d,
d d t,
t,
t.
T.
[inaudible] speed.
Of course,
the beat isn't going any faster.
The tempo is staying the same.
He's simply writing shorter note values,
which has a psychological impact.
As we've said several times of getup,
giving the sense of movement gathering speed here.
Uh,
it's like a train pulling out of the station.
We want to get on this train and this thing is really starting to roll after
five measures or so.
So it's a pretty nifty a fugue subject here and we're going to listen to this
now.
Uh,
and what I'd like to do is the following,
we're going to listen to the entire piece in addition to the entire piece.
Think about as the,
as the,
uh,
voices come in,
think about
where they're coming in.
Can you tell me what the trajectory of the voices is in the exposition?
And I'm going to turn out the lights here because sometimes it's good just to
kind of go off into your own world.
Close your eyes.
But I would like you to do the following thing,
kind of lean back,
get comfortable,
close your eyes.
But every time you hear,
uh,
the fugue subject,
hmm.
And so on,
every time you hear that fugue subject,
raise your hand so that I know you're recognizing that is the subject because
listening to a Fuchs,
it's basically one thing differentiating between a passage in which you've got a
statement of the subject and an episode where the Ain't no statement of the
subject.
Okay.
So this is a three minute and 22nd few and we're going to listen to the whole
thing,
but do raise your hand when you think that fugue subject is in there.
Soprano,
Alto,
tenor,
and now baby.
Yeah,
there it is.
One of those inner voices and it's a little bit disguise,
but it's in there.
Nice long sequence.
Yeah.
All the way up on top.
Their
episode descending sequence,
this time,
rising sequences here.
Polling sequence,
the base.
Okay.
So that's a wonderful few by Js Bach,
and we can,
we're going to talk more about this in section,
this idea how you can run your few parts this way,
or you could order them this way.
You can think of these constructs mathematically,
or you can think of the musically,
but you're all working with the same kind of material as you go out.
One final few by Glenn Gould,
who is going to teach you how to write a few as he sings a fume to you.
Okay?
Right.